[Music]
good evening and welcome to the 46th
annual Student Academy Awards thinking
back to that first ceremony in 1973 it's
hard to imagine that we had an American
president under investigation
the nation was facing a recession and
the Dodgers weren't going to the World
Series
how things have changed the truth is
over those decades some wonderful things
gratefully have remained constant the
importance of these awards what they
mean not just to the winners but to our
entire film community and also our
commitment to support and encourage
excellence in filmmaking at the
collegiate level for tonight's honorees
this is just a first step no one knows
what opportunities await you but for
some of you perhaps all you were on the
same path as past student Academy Award
winners who have gone on to receive 62
Oscar nominations and have won or shared
12 Awards
[Applause]
you should all be very proud of your
passion for your art and the talents
you've shared with us simply put you are
the future of film a future that is
diverse international and in every sense
extraordinarily bright on behalf of all
the members of the Academy we can't wait
to see the stories you next tale
congratulations
[Applause]
I would also like to thank the 752
Academy members who served as judges of
the submissions from students everywhere
from Prague Czech Republic to Provo Utah
to Guangzhou China we literally could
not do this without you and it is now my
up give it up and now it's my pleasure
to introduce an Academy member who is a
pioneer in digital marketing the founder
of Hollywood in pixels a nonprofit
promoting protecting and preserving our
industry's vast digital history she is
now paving a new future of movie
marketing through the lens of data at
Warner Brothers please welcome the chair
of the Student Academy Awards Executive
Committee
Bettina sharukh
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you David Student Academy Award
winners tonight we welcome you we
welcome you to our community and our
family and we celebrate the way our
family is growing with new voices new
faces and new perspectives we celebrate
the fact that inclusion just isn't the
right thing to do it is essential for
the future of film international markets
are often the key to box-office success
of the film and most of the world
doesn't look or sound like the people
who filled the seats at the first
Academy Award ceremony in 1929 or even
the first student awards Academy a
student Academy Awards in 1973 this year
we welcome winners from as far away as
China Israel Switzerland Poland Norway
Turkey and the United Kingdom and we
recognize that the heart of moviemaking
is all about perspective whose
perspective is being represented
what do you see through the look through
the camera lens who is behind the camera
itself Student Academy Award winners we
are counting on you to widen the lens
even more your generation of
storytellers won't just be the film's
film industry's most diverse we look to
you to make this industry the best it
can be
I know I am looking at some of the
people who shape the future of film the
winners in the seven categories this
year alternative experimental domestic
animation documentary and narrative and
international document the documentary
you know I did this perfectly
I really did you know it's again all you
guys show up and I'm like the
International narrative animation
document your film showcase an
incredible range of talent and I can't
wait to see what the future holds for
you all I also want to say a word of
thanks to my fellow members of the
Student Academy Awards Executive
Committee many of whom are in the
audience tonight I am so grateful for
the extra time you commit to this
program for many of us it is a passion
project so if everyone please give the
members and rounds of applause now it's
time to meet our first presenters to
celebrate the winners in the animation
and international animation categories
we are joined by two extraordinary
artists they have entertained movie fans
of every generation with their
exceptional wit and marvelous talent
with both live-action and animated films
you know them from the lego movies
21 Jump Street Cloudy with a Chance of
Meatballs and I'm going to fangirl a
little bit right now spider-man into the
spider verse and you don't know them
from their one-week comedy punch-up of
The Chronicles of Narnia voyage of the
Dawn Treader and I didn't know it either
and I worked on that digital campaign
please welcome the Academy Award winning
duo Phil Lord and Chris Miller
[Applause]
oh hi this is so rad and we are so
honored to be here you guys
congratulations everybody and as as we
well know the process of animation is
tedious long repetitive drawn-out the
same thing over and over and repetitive
what makes it a challenge to keep which
you know that makes it a real challenge
to keep animation feeling lifelike and
spontaneous very spontaneous Phil thank
you because it takes so long you have a
lot of chances to get it right and the
artists behind these three films met
that challenge and certainly got it
right from the Ringling College of Art
and Design there is game-changer the
story of an arcade prize determined to
keep a young girl from winning him and
taking him home Grendel from Brigham
Young University takes inspiration from
the epic poem Beowulf and not from the
2007 motion capture film Beowulf which
features Beowulf stabbing his way out of
a sea serpents eyeball while shouting
his own name and I highly recommend it
it is fantastic
I recommend the 3d version and the third
animated film in this category from USC
is - featuring two companions on a
mission toward the Sun who discover the
value of their friendship
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Hey - how many artificially intelligent
robots does it take to screw in about to
want to screw it in and want to watch
how we get sucked into the gravitational
[Music]
hi guys we're back and the bronze winner
is - I'm ray Acton University of
Southern California
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I want to start by taking my parents or
watching this from halfway around the
world I have a small message for that I
met baba this is a severe room of arsons
and I hope mom's not crying well they're
mostly students here so I want to thank
my teachers I wanted like Evert Lois for
always supporting me my unconventional
pursuits and I want to thank John
Brennan for introducing me to worship
production I would not be here without
him and I want to take my amazing
collaborators none of them had any time
to work on this project but somehow
we're here I guess that's the magic of
filmmaking
I want to thank Nick Lane for giving
voice to the story
I want to thank Raphael d'argent and
Federico Torre and Mathias Coppins
for the amazing score and I want to
thank arnesto Sandoval for always being
there
I want to thank imaging for technical
and emotional support and I want to
thank NIMH for her one-of-a-kind accent
and thank you to all my friends who
didn't help me on the film but they're
here I love you all and of course I
cannot get off the stage without
thanking the Academy for this
recognition it's it's been an incredible
week and as students getting out into
the real world we are faced with
uncertainty and this award that means
that maybe we are doing something right
it's incredibly meaningful so I want to
thank the Academy you think the
governor's the officers the Executive
Board everyone that made is possible
thank you
[Applause]
all right we switched places now who's
who I don't even know you'll never know
here's how you know Phil's hair is
filled with girls and Chris's is crisp
and straight that's a very handy
mnemonic and the silver medal goes to
honey
GameChanger Aviv mano Ringling College
of Art and Design let's not leave them
out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody sings heavy alright thank you
thank you guys so much
yeah I just want to start by saying that
I made this film hoping that it would
make people kind of think twice before
they give a discouraging look or or we
look or discouraging word to a little
girl that wants to get that monster
truck toy or that little boy that wants
the the dollhouse or the Easy Bake Oven
please make children feel safe to be
themselves from a young age it could
mean a world of difference
for their sense of identity and to the
person they grew up to be this film
would not be possible without the
support of so many people I want to
thank my family for always having my
back my mom
imani avodah my sisters Karen and
Danielle and my dad who was not with us
anymore but I'm pretty sure is throwing
one hell of a party up in heaven
watching tonight's ceremony he really
loved films so I imagine he's very happy
and proud that I'm get to make them to
Claire thank you for your constant love
and support for picking me up every
single time I didn't think I could do
this for the snacks and the coffee
breaks and the pep talks I would not be
here without you
thank you to my Ringling family my
instructors Heather Thompson Jeremy Kent
or Paul downs James Martin and the rest
of the CA faculty my production manager
Sydney Berman for those life-saving
deadlines and to my peers who were
always there to support and inspire
Thank You Nick gains word for the
gorgeous sound design and Garth know
each other for the beautiful score I
also want to thank my mentors for always
offering their wisdom your own Farkus
Kevin Andrus and cut some yang and of
course I'd like to thank the Academy for
this unbelievable honor
I am so humbled to be standing here
today thank you for getting this story
in front of so many eyes that means more
than anything to me I will never forget
the past week and all the incredible
people I've had the privilege of
I left my country about five years ago
and thanks to animation I found that
what I didn't know I was missing from my
life which was a sense of purpose
follow your passion follow your gut and
if you're not in a place in life where
you're where you're absolutely loving
what you're doing man
Peck you pack your bags and go look for
that thing that makes you tick
thank you so much and now for the least
suspenseful reveal who could it be the
gold award goes to Grendel and Kaylee
McCollum from Brigham Young
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much I just I want to
invite all the creators of Grendel who
are here please come up on the stage
with me and while they're coming up I've
got a long list of people that I would
like to thank first of all I'd like to
thank Brigham Young University and
especially my professors Brent Adams
Kelly Loosli South Holidays Sam Nielsen
Paris Eggbert and Erin Ludwig thank you
so much for all of your help and support
I'd like to thank the donors to the BYU
animation program you made making this
film possible and now I'd like to give a
special thank you to all of my
classmates and colleagues from BYU who
worked so hard and for so long on
Grendel and he trusted me in me from the
beginning to direct the film to what it
is now
thank you so much and thank you to the
composer Christian Walker and to the
sound designer Jared Richardson thank
you especially to Austin Rodriguez for
his help and excellent support as a
producer for Grendel thank you to all my
professors over the years and especially
to Craig Hanson who started me on my
artistic journey and fine and I would
like to thank all of the understanding
families of everyone who worked on our
film especially I would like to thank my
family my mom and my dad and all of my
sisters who are and always have been my
biggest supporters I love you all and
thank you and then I would like to thank
the Academy
I never thought those words would come
out of my mouth
but I'd like to thank the Academy for
acknowledging our film and all the hard
work that went into it
and thank you Sean Hector and Denise for
setting up all of the inspiring events
this week and for introducing me to the
other amazing and skilled student
academy winners I'm so humbled to have
our film stand next to theirs thank you
so much we're still here yeah
no one ever thinks the presenter yeah I
got like I opened three envelopes I got
two paper cuts International Animation
is a growing thriving competition that
is fast becoming a magnet for talented
young animators across the globe let's
take a look at daughter from the Czech
Republic
[Music]
[Applause]
please welcome this year's gold medal
winner in the International animation
category daria koshcheeva from filming
TV school academy performing arts prague
czech republic
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much on the 10th of
September five years ago my husband my
husband and me we arrived to Czech
Republic and we decided to try to live
in different country and we decided to
change our professions and it was so
hard time for us we we weren't really
sure what if we make a right decision
and the next day on the 11th of
September but in five years I've got the
call from Academy and Sean told me that
I want to do Tosca it was it was really
unbelievable and I at that time I
understood that we made the right
decision and I was happy that I was
happy that we were bright we were brave
enough yeah and that's why I really
would like to help this country Czech
Republic which really we had opportunity
to work there and I had the opportunity
to make my film in this country and I
would like to entertain Czech
cinematography fund which supports
supported us and trust us and I go in to
support us yeah and I want to I would
like to thank our school family in
Prague film school in Prague and
personally our jeans Daniel Holly and I
really think that we have this space to
work there and for we have no pressure
which is very important for us for us
and I would like to thank our teachers
who really have a very happy to help us
and I would like to thank Alexandra
Carranza who support my film now and
he's caring about distribution
I would like to thank Suzanne Aloha Java
our producer and for she always told me
that if you need this for your film you
will get it
be sure and I'm always very happy to
hear this from her and I want to have I
want to thank our producer Martin
vanda's for he gently provided us to the
professional world it was really
thankful very very helpful for us and I
would like to have to thank our editor
and dramatic Alexander car chef for he
he was so strict as a professional and
was so patient and kind as my husband
it's a pity I couldn't call all the
names of the members of my team I really
think he helped me you support me you
helped to make this film and I want to
thank my parents my mum and dad I
dedicated my film them and I wanted to
thank them for their laugh and I want to
thank Academy these days really changed
something in me and I think it is it is
incredible I think it will help me in
future and I really think for I think
Academy for this and for this week we
had here I think Sean and Denise and
Hector thank you so much and now I
really happy to ask my team who came
here to support me to stand up and you
deserve a big warm applause in this
place tonight thank you so much
[Applause]
thank you that's really cool
our professor used to smuggle films out
of Poland and and the the contribution
and the Czech Republic to animation
history is vast so thank you guys for
for joining that tradition and now to
present this year's winners for
international narrative and the
alternative experimental category here
is a woman who has done it all sitting
in the director's chair and standing up
for people and perspectives that too
often are forgotten and she is much much
cooler than us she's a multiple Grammy
winner a DJ Award nominee executive
producer of the HBO series insecure and
director of the upcoming highly
anticipated film Queen and slim
please welcome Melina Matsoukas
[Applause]
thank you to our presenters Phil and
Chris we appreciate your effort and
presenting it's often been said that
cinema transcends all borders and
boundaries that a great story can touch
the common humanity in all of us the
artists behind this year's international
narrative films from Switzerland Norway
and the UK have proven the truth of this
belief for they have given us films that
are relatable regardless of one's
language or culture from a Cal in
Switzerland the breakdown of a public
housing elevator and bonobo changes the
lives and feats of a disabled pensioner
a single mother and a young man
passionate about dance doggy-dog from
Westar Dolls Kristiania University
College takes us inside a disintegrating
relationship have ended by an
interrupted suicide attempt and November
first from the National Film and
Television School is centered around a
mother and daughter on a journey to
witness a long delayed execution
supposin fortress offensive in a little
funny glass Oh sir
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is yeah I bet almost to takes raw of
cash fast and intense mozilla mr.
Sinatra surest for someone so you better
familiar with their sugar missed so I
know them as mu nu gamma D roughly on
this is part monitor also tell use it
[Music]
cause Hatake depressed ahem yes I
[Music]
I used to love this now I used to think
it was beautiful just
[Music]
how everything's quiet you know it's
just different and now
just seeing a snow flurry it's like here
we go and that's why it's tough right
now
cuz I know it's coming
mr. Schorr was sentenced to death to the
brutal murder of 13 year old Ellis Baker
whose body was found by police in
December of 89
[Music]
Caroline stop it
[Music]
but for now we're going to
earlier jokes about how I was never
invited when I was a film student but
now I understand why not that was
incredible
and our bronze winner is Charlie Manson
for November 1st from the National Film
and Television School
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
somewhere down here there it is
wow this is incredible I'd like to thank
the Academy and that's insane
this means the world to me and it feels
surreal being here I want to thank Sean
Hector and Denise for this past week it
really has been a whirlwind the
highlight is probably being meeting just
an insane bunch of talented filmmakers
and more importantly amazing people I
feel so lucky to have my film amongst
tears and I'm lucky enough to have some
of the crew come up some which have
flown in from London yeah I want to
thank the amazing Teodoro Oliver she's
the producer who managed to pull off
shooting a US roadtrip film in the UK
stupid I know and always with the
biggest smile and this is Molly Manning
Walker who was the incredible DP and
Sofia Harrington who designed the
beautiful costumes and I want to send a
big thanks to the rest of the crew who
went above and beyond for this small
film we did it I definitely would not be
standing here if it wasn't for the
powerhouse performances that were
Lindsay Duncan it's fine miles being
with them on set was like being in a
master class I want to also thank the
NFC s and all the incredible sort the
tutors there Lesley Manning Bronco Annie
and seller and I finally want to give a
shout out to my family I love you thank
you so much for all the support and
thank you so much it's great thing here
thank you thank you
[Applause]
and our silver winner is okay Gregerson
for dog-eat-dog
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah okay so first of all I want to say
yeah just thank you so much to the
Academy for having us here it's a crazy
thing to say but really it's I mean it
really it's been so amazing the last few
days meeting the people from the Academy
and your amazing careers in that you saw
our film and voted it's it's truly an
honor
big honor so thank you so much I want to
thank everyone who worked on the film
obviously first of all my amazing
producer Rebecca thank you for for the
great ambition you had for the film and
for believing it everything you did it's
amazing and my cinematographer tokyo's
for being the best creative partner and
for being such an amazing photographer
and friend and everything and my editor
has been the sound guys Hansen lost that
did such an amazing job they're so
incredibly talented and it's been an
honor working with them I want to take
my actors might ask who is just
incredible I live have your umbrella and
of course an author that did the lead
role like she carries this whole film on
her shoulders and did such an amazing
job and seeing like a script come to
life like that it's just been incredible
my school of course I also want to thank
them and and really everyone that was a
part of making this film it's sometimes
it's crazy that even happens you know
from from like yeah the guy in the
middle of Norway that had a dentist one
in his freezer or two like yeah yeah the
costume designer is family that length
of the cabin it's just favors like that
that makes it possible so thank you so
so so much yeah yeah a special thank to
teachers and mentors life and faith
which is here today we that really means
a lot to us and of course also the other
winners
it's been so great to get to know you
and it's so inspiring to see all of your
projects and we can't wait to see what
you do next and hopefully we get maybe
we can work together sometime and on
behalf of the whole production we really
want to thank Eddie care for this great
script and you're such a great person
you're such a talented girl and we yeah
I'm really really good and our gold
medal winner is so l s Basha for bonobo
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone my heart is like boom
boom boom so wow this is amazing I
wasn't expecting the gold one
[Music]
guys I want to especially thank my my
precious and lovely team who supported
this filament so Dino ghoulia DBU hicho
Pauline Phelan I like a bad I'm gonna be
fast
Oscar positivo bein like Oh mister sub
the Salumeria team my family mom dad
sister my friends who came the cast
nickel mercy apartment Bahamas on the
Mohammadi family and the district of
loboda net cinema a cinema carries many
tradition one of them is to present a
protest cinema a cinema that highlights
the people against the powerful I hope
that this tradition will continue in
Hollywood and all over the world for
those who dream their work and never
give up everything is possible the proof
I'm here in front of you crazy so let's
hold on all together to our dreams and
ambitions my my action is really bad I'm
sorry and I want to say the biggest
thank you to the Academy and its member
for allowing me and my tiny clue from
Switzerland to share this moment and to
put this to put this film in front of a
mainstream audience so thank you again
to the Academy Awards for this unique
moment to shown the nice Hector and
everyone I met like fantastic upcoming
film directors impart be among them and
long live to cinema non view cinema or
thank you very much
[Applause]
Oh congratulations
I'm excited to introduce our next winner
in the category of alternative
experimental films patrons say from
Emerson College is a reimagining of
religion and history from the
perspective of the divine queer let's
take a look
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome the creator of patron
saint Jordan West
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my goodness gracious okay give me a
second
it is nerve-racking holy smokes this is
my producer Kendall
we had a family-size team so I wanted to
do my best to thank them all for taking
a chance on this film and investing time
and talent that went above and beyond my
wildest dream well we made a wild film
I want to thank Kendall her producer who
is undying commitment to these projects
occurred way before patron saint's on
this film she not only produced but
first a deed and acted damn that's like
a mm-hmm
thank you for your years of hard work
and belief in my vision I know words
will never do justice to the level of
appreciation I have for you thank you
also to change in and Greg also if you
worked on the film come come up I'm
nerve-racked so if you work on the film
yeah yeah thank you thanks thank you
also to change in and Greg I couldn't
imagine shooting a piece without y'all
and Isaac and Josue you've also been
with me since day one I've never shot a
film without their support they're my
family thank you to the stars Monroe
yeah Leah DeSean and Jesse to the art
team Po and Sonny for manifesting my
vision with such few resources to the
hair and makeup team headed by jaws and
Bianca to all of our other contributors
thank you to my family
it is a privilege in this world to have
a family who supports and loves you
unconditionally and not when I take for
granted thank you to my friends Alex
Sean Jan Chaka Elam and Zach for your
support especially throughout
post-production thank you so much to the
Academy for selecting our film for this
honor it means an incredible amount to
demonstrate how meaningful beautiful and
impactful and alternative media can be
especially when reframing exploring the
lights of people usually designated as
alternative when as for whom he created
art Felix gonzalez-torres all simply
said his partners named Ross his work
was a love letter and I shared that
sentiment that art is an exchange
between individuals that is personal and
can speak to the universal this piece is
a love letter to my career community and
the possibility of a fashion in so many
ways to Kenan Jamal especially when
words fail
I want to extend a huge thank you to
Jamal for trusting me with his art when
you see yourself in your community on
screen within a grim reality it is
deeply meaningful to have the
opportunity to create a fantastical
environment which people like you can
live
I hope media continues to explore the
possibilities of portraying the magic of
our community in a ways that tests and
push the ways we are conceptualized for
the screen I'm so grateful for the
economy for allowing us to be part of
this history and do you want to say
something thank you to Jordan thank you
to the Academy and to my mama
and to Winslow and to chase thank you so
much guys thank you and now to present
the winners for documentary films please
welcome an Academy Award nominated
nominated primetime enemy award-winning
director producer she doesn't run away
from the world's most difficult and
divisive issues she runs towards them
and challenges her audiences to face
them with courage and candor from
domestic abuse to drug addiction human
rights to mental illness she is a
chronicler of our collective conscience
an Academy Governor representing the
documentary documentary branch a
producer and director whose
groundbreaking documentaries are a
searing as they are sincere please
welcome the individual Rory Kennedy
thank you thank you milena and good
evening everyone
what is the power of a documentary the
power is truth documentary should always
inform because it's truth after all
that as they say sets us free and I
believe more than in any other time in
my life that we need more truth and more
facts in our public dialogue but more
than this when a filmmaker fine said
special subject that story that just has
to be told the real power of a
documentary is to make us act 59 years
ago Adlai Stevenson introduced my uncle
John F Kennedy by comparing him to de
mis theas Stephen said Stevenson said
that in classical times when cicero
finished speaking people said how well
he spoke but when Damis the--is had
finished speaking people said let us
march at its most powerful great
documentaries touch that part of our
spirit which says let us march together
tonight's winners domestic and
international have already become foot
soldiers in that long March to summon
our sense of responsibility
responsibility to cause conscience and
conviction and in the most important
aspect of that journey to help us
understand each other better our winners
come from different countries and
different backgrounds as students they
range from UC Berkeley to Columbia
University Villanova University to the
national film television and theater
school in Poland but to borrow the title
of one of our entrants in this category
they each have something to say and we
all need to listen to them come along
for the journey inside the mystery of
the human brain as an 11
year-old who struggles to speak a
sentence but makes beautiful music by
ear bear witness to the story of
undocumented farmworkers victimized
first by a broken immigration system and
then by the ravages of climate change
experience the long anticipated reunion
of a young woman with her birth family
in China and wrestle with the cycle of
tragedy for black men right here at home
these are the stories and now let's meet
our storytellers there is a single
winner in the category of the
International Documentary from Poland
this is family squared the
generalizability de mama
Christine her uniquor Dada woman a more
general woman but with Himanshu an turn
in to hide the new Java code in Java
tada - tada - Shifu the lyonie an epic
would happily tectona for it at restrict
a little a thousand feet a family
endeavor payloads amount of over
legality
[Music]
if you don't want to buy your first
parents inside do you buy them forever
yeah it's less you could pop up next to
them you owe me rocky please welcome
this year's gold medal winner for
International Documentary Ethan soon
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you all
after all this
okay so I want to say thank you to the
Academy because of you the Academy got
the chance to stand here to challenge
myself to speak in front of so many
people here so thank you Academy's Thank
You Sean Denise and Hector for taking
care of us firstly I like to thank Lola
and her both Belgian and Chinese family
part of them are here Lola and Christine
could you maybe stand up Thank You Lola
Christine Patrick
Justine Cammy after you as well as I
call them the Chinese part through ie
the UN the UN leadership lives alone and
all the last cousins without you the
film would never be made thank you
and of course I'd like to thank my
lovely crew and so supportive a alyssum
a cinematographer Dorota
my editor and my Santa Donna pandava and
the colorist editor and the
extraordinary animator and sound design
for the interim video editor and
Nicholas but unfortunately they didn't
have chance to show the intro video but
I want to thank them because for their
great great efforts and hard work
I also want to thank everyone at my
school the national the Polish National
Film School in wood especially my
artistic supervisors attack blood and
Andrea nice diversion panty is gooey and
really important gavage the Russia of
Sparta first mantra
castilla-la practicing where I belong
which ends in a Talia's dimensional Mia
one chance just drop you want and fill
both partial open
tank we observed and now most
importantly I want to thank my mom my
dad and it's me
thank you for your unconditional love
and endless support thank you she's any
man
[Applause]
[Music]
you did a fantastic job speaking and now
a look at the extraordinary efforts of
this year's winners from right here at
home that was hard on the phrase I mean
today was insane disco career yeah see
90 possible
kaylynn todas esas say problemas todavía
no porque nosotros los hispanos como que
céntimos que no son Ali knows viola the
new Nora
otama so London they wanted an apartment
and release a espera que hacen el
momento
there was a session
a mucho trabajo key pero lo hace la
gente que a veces no tiene su so
pimentos bin e son los más purple atados
cuando un desastre de estos los
incendios trajeron a la superficie estos
problemas
porque bein muchas personas que estaban
las sombras
[Music]
estamos are you presenting this throw
away systems in the sameness
[Music]
I'm lost
searching high and low for a history far
behind and buried deep family I'll never
know an eternal sleep a slave masters
name mine to keep and I'm lost
I'm told to go back to go forward but I
can't go back
family tree chopped down and it won't
grow back and I'm lost
[Music]
when I was growing up I was taught in
American history books but Africa had no
history and neither did I
that I was a savage about whom the less
said the better who had been saved by
Europe and brought to America and of
course I believed it I didn't have much
choice those the only books they're
worth
[Music]
[Music]
Bradshaw was a beautiful baby
I never realized said beautifully was
happy joyful for whatever reason Brian
Charles doesn't see the value of
language you can't make friends if you
can't talk it's like having your mouth
taped and somebody send you into room
and says make friends I do think that as
I get older it's gonna be hard for the
first time in his life he started saying
no school we don't know what happened
because they can't tell us and you're
constantly second-guessing everything
you're doing daddy this is the best rule
they don't have to take
a warning that we're not going to find
the place went over for September you
can do so much the most important thing
is that we give him every opportunity to
demonstrate that we just need some
school to be like we'll take a chance on
him
[Music]
and now here are the winners in the
category of documentary domestic film
schools the bronze medal winner in the
documentary category is Eva Rendell all
that remains University of California
birthday
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi could I ask my cinematographer
Marianne to come up and join me
[Applause]
so the North Bay fire swept through
Northern California's wine country
during my first month of grad school at
the time it was the deadliest natural
disaster in California's history they
burned uncontrolled for 23 days and we
heard story after story of the physical
devastation that they left behind but
what I heard less of were the stories of
those who live in the shadows of wine
country the 50,000 undocumented
immigrants who make up the backbone of
Napa and Sonoma is tourism and
agricultural industries because of their
immigration status they were left most
vulnerable after the fires when I set
out to make this film a year later it
was their story that I wanted to tell so
first and foremost I want to thank
Consuela Medrano who is a heroine in
this film and in her community in Napa
gustavo vargas and all of the people who
had to remain anonymous
but were brave enough to trust me with
their story i'd like to thank everyone
at the UC Berkeley Graduate School of
Journalism who made this film possible
my advisers Carrie Lozano Don Porter
Casandra Herman Lauren Capps
Chris O'Day and Mike Shen my fearless
cinematographer Mary Ann Curtis kettle
who made this film beautiful
and everyone in the 2019 documentary
class who provided endless feedback and
moral support thank you thank you to
Andrew Ching Jacob Bloomfield Miss ratch
and William fritsch who composed the
music for the film and Jim Labrecque and
Berkley sound artist whom artists who
mixed it I'd like to thank my parents
and my brother who are here tonight
thank you for believing me
and supporting me every step of the way
and last but not least I'd never thought
I would say this but thank you to the
Academy thank you so much for this
incredible honor
[Applause]
and the silver medal goes to Abby
Lieberman and Joshua Lucas for something
to say Columbia University
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening it's where it says silver
winter acceptance speech here sorry to
go behind the Gary way of course we'd
like to start off by thanking the
Academy and all of its members who voted
for us this is an incredible honor and
we can't begin to believe that we are
here right now especially among our
fellow winners who each and every film
knocked us out in ways that we could
never have expected so congratulations
to you all as well um to Columbia
Journalism school we are forever
grateful and everybody there thank you
for helping us and inspiring us along
the way
to our funders who believed in our film
early on the Poulter Center and the
National Academy of Television Arts and
Sciences in the New York Chapter thank
you to Judith or our advisers who run
our program thank you for your countless
hours your patience and your effort at
every every turn of this story - Betsy
West our editor-at-large or insight and
your advice is incredible and you're
forever grateful
to Dan and our entire documentary class
back at Columbia
thank you so much for your endless
support and your guidance throughout
this year um we love you guys um to our
crew which is Josh and I but -
re-recording mixer at Campbell thank you
for believing in our film and spending
such an incredible amount of time on it
- our composer and my dear friend Aaron
Gilman you are so incredible talented
incredibly talented and we thank you to
our colorist Adam greenberg also my
close friend thank you so much and to
Jude / Mueller who thank you for your
contribution to the soul of this film
and to the Khans family we are forever
grateful oh we have to of course thank
our executive producer pamela hogan who
gave as much of her heart to our film as
we did and she was extremely patient
with us and very kind and encouraging
and we love you and thank you for
everything
of course I'm sorry I have a list of
people here all right don't
oh no okay here we go okay uh-huh it's
somewhere it's by my seat I'm sure I
have to I have to thank my sisters Terry
Amy and Stacy and their kids AJ Haley
Brooke Adriana
Chris and Leo it was the cutest person
here see right now he's wearing a tuxedo
it's this big he's adorable I have to
thank Neil Curtis Curtis Coleman and my
my best friend and the woman I love
Bianca Hayward and I have to thank my
dad who's here as well flew here from
Florida living a comfortable life in
retirement and and my mom Debbie who
made it here today which I'm extremely
grateful for and I would like to thank a
person for mostly Swartz my close close
friend for introducing us to the kinds
and changing our lives and there's
forever um she knew my parents my mom
and dad Mike and Lisa oh this is hard I
thought I was gonna be thank you for
believing in me always for allowing me
to sleep on your couch at 4:00 a.m.
because your apartment was closer to
school than mine you are my biggest fans
my biggest role models I would not be up
here without your constant love your
pride and your joy to my brother Danny
my sister-in-law Samantha and my
one-year-old niece Caroline I mean never
stopped believing in me never stop
supporting me never stopped offering me
of mice or just being there throughout
this entire process I'm so lucky to have
you and I love you all
it's my alley family Pat Frank and Joe
thank you for letting me turn your home
into my Edit Bay for two weeks treat
and for your constant support and love
to my best friend Mike you are my rock
you're my biggest support system thank
you for believing in me and for being
proud of me no matter how many late
nights I spent in the Edit Bay when my
brain was in comes from places you amaze
me and I love you and now to the most
important people the kinds Maryanne
Brian Margie you opened up their lives
in your hearts to us not knowing what
this journey what the khamar really who
we even were your trust is something
that has guided us and motivate us
throughout this entire making of this
film
thank you for sharing with us in the
deepest and most intimate parts of your
life you are incredible and if you guys
can please come up here to you all you
[Applause]
sorry for a little long there's two of
us so it's a little harder but Brian
Charles and Thomas you are smart you are
brave
you inspire thank you for allowing us to
come into your lives and to share that
with the rest of the world never stop
believing in yourselves and from my part
I would like to dedicate this award to
Jonathan Resnick
who's near and dear to my heart who
inspired me to start this crazy
journalism journey so long ago from the
beginning I miss you and I know that
you're smiling up there somewhere yeah
thank you for indulging us I know where
two of us so longer than you might
expect but we can't we can't step off
the stage without also without also
saying a thank you - no thank you
sincere word of gratitude to all the
journalists around the world who put
their lives in danger to tell the truth
and to speak truth to power and the
people around this country who do the
same and who stand up every day to do
the right thing we wouldn't be standing
in front of you if we weren't
journalists first in filmmakers second
and we wanted to say thank you to all of
those folks out there
[Applause]
oh did you guys freaking something okay
the gold medal goes to princess Garrett
Sankofa no the University
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so it's a good village to make this film
so can a village come up riptide faster
quicker
[Music]
so two years ago on October 17th a group
of privileged Villanova students
embarked upon a journey like never
before enrolling into a social justice
documentary class founded by the amazing
Hezekiah Lewis sophist did not know we
were going to Africa especially Ghana
shoutout caleb abruptly we found
ourselves on set in ghana filming
footage for a story we had only
partially outline it took many intense
discussions many possible story lines
and lots of research to comes to this
thought-provoking documentary Sankofa
sang cold for literally means go back
and fetch it you need to go back to your
past in order to understand the present
african-american history did not start
with slavery it interrupted it our film
addresses the loss of African identity
and black males in both Ghana and Africa
in our film we talk about the loss of
African identity in the blackmail and
how that paralleled
disconnect has been a direct negative
result of colonialism and slavery on
behalf of the whole riptide pictures
team we would like to thank first and
foremost God's Way Anderson and Marquis
granham who are principal characters for
allowing us into their lives and sharing
their stories we would also like to
thank our academic experts chichi a coma
and Amar'e Johnson for giving us helpful
historical insight the stories of God's
Way and marquees represent those of
millions around the world who are
dealing with a historical disconnect
from modes of slavery and colonialism
thank you to the Academy for this
incredible honor to the North family and
the Waterhouse foundation thank you for
your generous donations and your
continued support throughout our process
a huge thank you to father Peter Donahue
and Dean Adele Linda Meyer from
Villanova University for your passion
and willingness to provide resources to
ensure that Sankofa would be seen by
everyone to our professors our mentor
Hezekiah Lewis all we can say is we're
all I can say is we are endlessly
grateful for you when we were in the lab
and so four or five in the morning you
were there with us when we needed
guidance or advice you were there for
all of us through your sacrifice and
dedication this program and storytelling
we are able to share some Cofield on
numerous platforms you gave us the
freedom and responsibility to have
complete say over our film giving us a
space and confidence to make Sanko fho
thank you for providing students
opportunity on campus for creativity
passion and social justice for pushing
us to make a film that is raw and real
for challenging us in our own personal
and team growth Sankofa would not be
what it is today without you or your
family's support especially your wife
leash leash we love you to our families
and friends we are so sorry we all
disappeared for like a year to make this
film there are many late nights many
missed classes and we don't encourage
that missed calls and missed events for
our phone you were all you all were and
continue to be our support system thank
you for all you do we love you from the
bottom of our hearts and I'm almost done
guys so Coco we'll always be about the
art of storytelling using the art of
film to break down cultural barriers
challenge our own preconceived notions
of the world and share this with others
above all we always want to challenge
perspectives and promote dialogue among
people so that we can begin and continue
to talk about the issues rather than
hide from them in Sankofa we are bold
with our story we believe it is
important to tell the truth within
context and clarity reminding young
black men and women to tell their truth
writing young black men and women that
they are more than what society says
they are we will all keep - we will all
keep pushing to share Sankofa in to
promote advocacy with pure intentions
above all it is meant to invoke everyone
to think about their position in these
systems of oppression that continue to
infest our country today and to act to
make concrete structural change there is
no one-size-fits-all solution to this
problem but being complacent is not the
answer if you are not fighting to end
the problem you are the problem
[Applause]
[Music]
one of the running themes here is all
these students stay up till 4:00 in the
morning work very hard Samuel Goldwyn
for whom this theater is named once said
pictures are for entertainment messages
should be delivered by Western Union
wellmaybe Goldwyn never imagined a film
like the Academy award-nominated El
Norte or an auteur like the great
Gregory Nava Gregory second film was
deemed culturally significant and added
to the Library of Congress's National
Film registry thirty-five years later
that work of art still echoes in Barrios
and border towns where everyday families
put their lives in the hands of coyotes
and cross a desert in search of hope
Roger Ebert called it a Grapes of Wrath
of our time to introduce this year's
winner for narrative film someone who
needs no introduction the visionary
behind El Norte and so many other
unforgettable films the groundbreaking
Greg Nava
[Music]
thank you so much Rory thank you what a
wonderful event isn't this incredible
I'm just sitting there I am so inspired
by everything that I've seen and heard
and I think that we should give all of
these filmmakers a tremendous round of
applause they truly are our future
bienvenidos a todos a muchisimas gracias
narrative film is the art of convincing
an audience that the unfolding fiction
before their eyes is real that may sound
like the work of magicians like David
Copperfield or Penn & Teller
but it's more than a magic trick it's a
powerful medium to pull you into
characters and conflicts that capture
your attention and it won't let you go
all of this year's narrative winners
pull you in and take you where the
filmmakers need you to go into the days
and nights the mind and the heart of a
transwoman mechanic who touches our
heart and makes us think anew into a
dystopic future where workers may be
supplanted by robots but humanity
confounds engineering and into the
wonderfully subversive delay David
versus Goliath story of an imaginative
immigrant boy pushed into the scenery
but who ends up on center stage these
films all from the American Film
Institute are our winners
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh y'all see it now - before you
[Music]
now
[Music]
people meet our new colleague William
he'll be shadowing shampoo until he gets
the hang of our kitchen see what a Polly
Kasahara nice to meet you chef - it's
like you've asked either - yeah yeah
yeah classically I got almost all to
answer the plane miss crystal last year
promised that if F is speaking would
finish of obviously she I was thinking
now we can show miss Bristol that were
way more than his background but we're
supposed to be background trees
[Music]
we special trees trees that dance sing
[ __ ]
so accents when he sees us he might even
give us lies what exactly do you want
sticky no no no feeling just poses miss
Kristin I'm an actor I can get rid of
any accident
wish me luck
[Music]
and the envelope please I've always
wanted to say that and the bronze award
for narrative goes to Oh mayor been
shocked hair
never
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow Oh Oh and now I see what he means
with the TV screen it's right here um
thank you so much to the Academy for
this huge honor it means so much to us
um and thank you Shawn Denise and Hector
for this amazing week first I want to
introduce you to these amazing
filmmakers up here with me
iris young producer Tatiana's vera
production designer Yvonne Shaw editor
Sydney meadow co-writer and zlingly with
cinematographer thank you to our star
Lee or mauka oh hey um so the amazing
cast and crew and to everyone who
supported our movie so three number
three is actually based on my experience
growing up in Texas yes this is a Texan
accent y'all as the newly immigrated boy
while I dreamt of becoming to the next
Meryl Streep instead because of my
strong Israeli accent I was cast as
flour number four lamp number two and
sad cloud number six so I decided to put
up my own plays in our small living room
and invite my own crowd in those plays
at home I cast myself as the lead no
drama teacher was going to convince me
that I was doomed to be background
forever making this film was our way to
prove it but this movie wouldn't exist
without all those people who saw me as
more than sad cloud number six first
Michael urban RAF I mentor well who
always encouraged us to keep the things
that others questioned the best stuff in
the movie are the things we got the most
notes on and they're all still there
because of you so thank you Michael for
believing in us so much and being the
best mentor ever
thank you to my mom and dad every dream
I ever had came true because of you when
I said I wanted to be a dancer you found
me the best ballet school in Texas do
you know how hard that is y'all when I
said I didn't get a part in the school
play you built a stage in our living
room and
me a sold-out audience you told me that
that the capacity was 5 which meant sold
out and when I said I wanted to move
abroad and study at AFI even though I
knew we couldn't really afford it you
said well it's cheaper than USC third I
want to thank AFI before moving the year
I had never slept out of my house and
was terrified I won't make it here but a
if I turned out to be the best home I
could have could have asked for
literally the restrooms are so much
cleaner than in my house the AC usually
always sometimes works and there's
always an animal to feel a deer a coyote
or a first-year student and at 11:00
p.m. and we were working late hours at
AFI people would come and ask don't you
want to go home I would say that I'm
already there I'd like to think Patti
where Susan Dred Scott Vanessa Hayes
Peter Markham Barrie Sabbath Rob Spira
Andrew Wagner and everyone at a of fine
and lastly I want to share this award
with all those who are still put in the
background with the outsider seeking
acceptance when it seems impossible and
we've the dreamers who will do whatever
it takes to prove to the world that a
tree isn't just a tree thank you very
much thank you
[Applause]
and the silver medal for narrative film
goes to how Jim for the chef
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well first let's spring my team up
please first allow me to take a moment
to say this next line perfectly thank
you to the Academy for this incredible
honor it really feels like a dream come
true moment and thank you to Shawn actor
the nice and amazing team for this
incredible week and before I introduce
my team just a few things that I want to
mention going up in China and coming to
the US when I was 15 and spending the
past 10 years working hard trying to
pursue my filmmaking dream I always
found me trying to prove myself to one
person and that is my father
[Applause]
and I always it was always my dream to
see him you know maybe impressed by the
work that I do or like one day maybe say
to me you know son I'm proud of you
those kind of things in this past summer
I was home I sat down with him and then
the two of us I decided to show him the
chef during the entire time I was super
nervous and then afterwards he just sat
there quietly and then drink from his
teacup and man that was the longest sip
of tea I've ever experienced in my life
and and then he pat on my shoulder and
then he said to me it's not bad and I
know it's very far away from you know
saying I'm proud of you but you know if
you know him
this is the best line or the closest
line to show his love to me so so to him
and to my family in China thank you so
much for supporting me supporting my
strange dream in filmmaking Papa mama
cinema usually a lot ordered richer and
now let me introduce my team and this is
my producer writer ethica and thank you
so much for bringing is such a
compelling original story to me and
trusting in me and then my production
designer Boni Mamba my writer con la
ceiba NASA and our amazing cast allen
role and our lead actor team lau
our editor Huang way do in our cast
Raymond MA and our composer Centurion
and also to those who are not here with
us today I was in tog refer carlo
mendoza our actor queen van Haney tab
Makar no Jaime John production manager
Don Hmong you'd have some design eFilm
torpedo pictures and many other cast and
crew who helped on the film they're my
they're my collaborators my friends my
mentors and I can wait to make more
films with them also to the sloan
Foundation and our sponsors share among
curtain loggia and all our friends and
families who donated to us thank you so
much for the generous support without
you guys this film would never happen
and in of course to my school AFI I
couldn't be more proud to be among so
many talented filmmakers at the school
and thank you to my classmates
especially lo Cindy Andrew Shue and my
professors Peter Martin and drew Wagner
Rob's berra berra Sabbath Patty West
Vanessa Haines Steven Leight Hill Neil
Kenton hey deal Abbott in Thomas Mahoney
also to 1fi alarm Julian Higgins who was
also a student having a word winner in
2011 thank you for being my friend my
mentor in my role model apologize if I
didn't get to mention everyone but to
all of those who have supported us along
the way
we're truly truly grateful and last but
not least back to the Academy thank you
again for recognizing our short film in
recognizing a story about rebuilding
human connections despite our
differences
and as in Asian director just want to
thank the pioneers in our community
director and Lee I have to put his name
with me
hero Castle corrida bond jang-ho and
many many others who have paved the road
for us and I can't wait to join the
community and share more stories of our
community together thank you so much
[Applause]
and finally the gold medal winner is
Asher Jelinski for Miller & Son
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I like to invite all the cast and crew
to please come up with me come on
thank you so much to the Academy for
putting on this event and for supporting
all of us emerging filmmakers the whole
week has been so incredible and I've met
so many really talented people so thank
you for the effort that it takes to put
on an event like this thank you to the
faculty at AFI you have been so
inspiring and you've really pushed me to
grow as a filmmaker I really am grateful
to that thank you also to my fellow
classmates some of you are on stage with
me and thank you to my parents for
encouraging me to pursue my passions in
life thank you to the cast and crew who
worked so hard to bring this home to
life especially all these folks here I'm
going to read a couple names Kate Joe
Morris Robert Nachman Robert Aguirre
Celinda Zhou Russell Bost Michael Urban
Ryan Cutrona Travis hammer Alexandre
gray and the lead of Miller and son
Jesse James Keitel in telling a story
centered around a transgender character
it was really important for me to have
authenticity in the casting and I
couldn't be more grateful to share this
experience with Jesse Jesse this film
wouldn't have been nearly as impactful
without all of your talent so thank you
[Applause]
I made this movie because I wanted to
explore the feeling of
compartmentalization
I am gender non-binary and because my
identity is one that's not widely
understood I often find myself
confronted with the choice of whether to
speak up or to stay silent whether or
not you identify as transgender or
gender non-conforming I think everyone
can relate to the experience of wanting
to belong in the world I'm sure everyone
in this room has your own stories about
masking feelings in order to fit in to
move ahead or to protect yourself with
Miller & Son I was interested in looking
at the compromises people are faced with
on the path toward authenticity so thank
you again to the Academy for championing
all of our stories and for allowing us
the space to share the stories that mean
so much to us thank you
[Applause]
I am so deeply impressed not only by the
incredible talent and the beautiful
films that these young filmmakers have
made but by their humility and their
generosity is this tradition that they
have all brought to us of bringing all
of the people who worked on their films
up on the stage with them that is such a
beautiful thing because we do not make
films alone families make films and
tonight we witnessed a beautiful display
of Familia in making beautiful films
about humanity thank you all so much and
[Applause]
I want to congratulate you all enjoy
this moment savor this moment but as you
leave here look ahead not backwards
because we are looking to you to lead
and you can only lead in one direction
and that is forward and as you do that
know that your family of filmmakers has
the highest expectations for you we
expect that like Chris and Phil your
drawings will begin someone else is
daring we expect that like Molina you
will break barriers and widen the
world's lens we expect it like Rory you
will force us to face our best and our
worst in the mirror and come out
resolved to be as Hemingway said
stronger at the broken places so keep
doing what got you here in the first
place be authentic be audacious go with
your gut go outside the box and never be
afraid to own your narrative we're
counting on you to make the films that
only you can dream of Student Academy
Award
you're already our leading lights now be
our North Bavetta Bay and blaze the path
for the next generation thank you all
and good night
[Applause]
you